[موسيقى]
20 عاما مضت والعربيه في صداره المشهد
السعودي عبر شبكه مراسليها الذين يتابعون
اولا باول كيف تصدت السلطات السعوديه في
حرب شرسه لتنظيم القاعده حتى القضاء عليه
هذا وجه من اوجه تغطيه العربيه للشان
السعودي ولنا في نشره الرابعه تحديدا
سنوات وذكريات لا تحصى مع مشاهدينا نتابع
[موسيقى]
خاص من بينهم امريكي وفليبيني قتلوا في
اطلاق نار في ضاحيه الراكه بمنطقه الخبر
الشرقيه سعوديه تضرب طوقنا امنيا على هذا
المجمع
وثلاثه فلبينيين قتلوا في الهجوم
كان انه بهذا يعبر او يحقق رسالته فمن
الواضح انه مخطئ عمر الزبيدي العربيه
مدينه الخبر
قال بيان لوزاره الداخليه السعوديه ان
العمليه الامنيه التي جرت في المدينه
المنوره اسفلت عن مقتل اثنين من المطلوبين
منهم صالح الاوفي القيادي والبرز في تنظيم
القاعده في السعوديه في منتصف عقد
التسعينيات من القرن الماضي نشط العوفي في
الاراضي الافغانيه الى جانب ابي معاذ
الخزقي
بوزاره الداخليه في الفتره الماضيه كشف عن
وجود بعض الخلايا المختبعه داخل الاحياء
السكنيه اعلنت قوات الامن السعوديه القاء
القبض على خمسه مسلحين على صله بالهجوم
الانتحاريه على اكبر منشاه في العالم
لتكرير النفط في هذا الشريط ظهرت صور
المنافدين الخمسه الذين قتلت اثنان منهم
في عمليه
[موسيقى]
هذه الخليه هي تمثل تنظيم القاعده منذ
بدايه
نشاطه في المملكه
[موسيقى]
الصوت الان الحقيقه شوي
يقال بان
يقال ان ما انت مركز مفاسد
ووجهت السعوديه القاعده كان بيان لدول
الخليج الاستجابه لطلب الرئيس اليمني بردع
ميليشيا الحوثي وتنظيمي القاعده وداعش على
البلاد الهدف هو ايجاد معادله توازن في
خبر عاجل ورد قبل قليل القوات الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه تقصف مواقع
للانقلابيين الحوثيين في اليمن المساله
وصلت الى حدها الاقصى
[موسيقى]
واعلن بيان قياده التحالف عن انتهاء عمليه
عاصفه الحزم وقال البيان ان عمليه جديده
اطلق عليها اعاده الامل
[موسيقى]
من الرياض الى متابعيها في السعوديه
والخليج والعالم تنطلق اليوم من غرفه
اخبار العربيه نشره الرابعه ضمن نشرات
الاخبار من العاصمه السعوديه نبدا بابرز
العناوين قناه العربيه تفتح مقرها في
العاصمه الرياض وتبدا عمليات البث بتقنيات
متقدمه
[موسيقى]
استوديوهاتنا في رياض الكاتب الصحفي جاسر
الجاسر سجل جاسر حياك الله نبارك لانفسنا
ونبارك لك ايضا وصول العربيه الى العشرين
اليوم هذه مناسبه يعني مميزه ولافته لانه
مو فقط للعربيه للاعلام العربي ككل
يعني في جانب دائما مشكله الاعلام العربي
كان
غلبه النبره الخطابيه واحيانا تشنج
الايديولوجي العربيه حتى حتى انتم من
المذيعين ما اشعر انا بحاله هدائيه معكم
مش خطابيين يعني ترتاح تتلقى الخبر
بتلقائيه وعفويه في وضع الطبيعي ولا تحس
ان المذيع يدفعك الى موقف معين او الزمك
باتجاه معين او يحاول ان يشحن المشاهد
ما تعبناك يعني كثير في التغطيات
والمناسبات
ونرحب بضيفنا ايضا من دبي استاذ عبد الله
بجاد العتيبي الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بك معنا
من دبي استاذ عبد الله حياك الله معنا في
الذكرى العشرين لنجاح العربيه في تغطيه
الاحداث حول العالم حياك الله
لعلي ابدا
اهلا وسهلا ومبروكين جميعا على
عقدين من الزمن من نجاح العربيه اللي
صراحه شكلت فارق في التاريخ الاعلام
والاعلام السياسي العربي بشكل عام شكرا لك
استاذ عبد الله العلي ابدا معك ساد جاسر
بما انك معانا في الاستديو هنا بالرياض
يعني منذ 2003 العالم مر باحداث وظروف
ومواقف سياسيه ربما غيرت ايضا المشهد من
حول العالم كيف المسار او ما المسار الذي
اختارته العربيه في تغطياتها وانا اتحدث
على الصعيد الاقليمي والصعيد العالم يعني
عندنا غزو العراق عندنا احداث 11 سبتمبر
وحتى الربيع العربي
لو ما كانت في مثل العربيه في تلك الفتره
يعني ما كان في صوت لنقل اقليمي كانت
المحطات يعني الاحتضار موجوده كما ذكرت
قبله هيدروجيه محليه بحته فبالتالي ما كان
هناك خطاب كان في تحديات كثيره المشاهد
العربي بالدرجه الاولى لم يكن لديه منصه
تستطيع ان توصله للاول احداثه ما يحدث
تستطيع ان تنقله من الزاويه الضيقه الخاصه
بتلك الجهه او الايدولوجيا المعينه الى
دائره الحدث الى التوازن فبالتالي لما
ظهرت العربيه اذا كانت في فتره حرج جدا
وكانت ابرز سمات تلك الفتره طبعا
مساله غزو العراق كان ايضا الارهاب يعني
يضرب في مناطق كثيره في العالم العربي
وخصوصا في السعوديه والخليج الكبير اللي
واجهته مع القاعده وغيرها مهم جدا في
عمليه انه في تلك الفتره ما كان في صوت
يعني كانت العربيه تقوم بهذا الدور بشكل
كبير
وتحليليا والموقف والجانب الاخر انها تعزز
يعني قناه تتبنى مواقف لنقل اخلاقيه معينه
في سياق تحقيق الاستقرار الدعم المعلومه
وليست المعلومه بمعنى التحريضي كما يحدث
احيانا او بمعنى
في نقل معلومه بدون مساس او بما يشجع
الاستقرار والطمانينه وبمشكل ايضا موقفا
ضد العمليات خاصه مثلا في الارهاب في تلك
الفتره او النقل المجسد والصريح للحدث
بموضوعيه احنا ما نقول حياديه للاعلام ما
في حياديه لكن موضوعيه حضور في الميدان
نبره متوازنه في الخطاب منح الاطراف
الاصوات المختلفه الكامله وبالتالي تصل
للمشاهد او المتابع الصوره كامله مجسده
بدون زوايا مظلمه وبدون مسارات مجبر عليها
او مسارات الزمنيه
في العربيه خالد يعني الموضوعيه بشكل كبير
كامل والحكم طبعا للمشاهد دائما وابدا هنا
اذهب اليك استاذ عبد الله صديقي العزيز
الذي يرافقنا دائما في التغطيات في
الحوارات في التعليقات استاذ عبد الله بن
بجاد ضيفي من دبي حول هذه النقطه تحديدا
اللي ذكرها الاستاذ جاسر مساله الارهاب
والتطرف تعلم بانه هذه الظاهره اجتاحت
معظم مناطق العالم وان كانت بدرجات
متفاوته وعانت منطقه الشرق الاوسط كثيرا
من هذه والخليج والسعوديه تحديدا
اريد ان اقف معك استاذ عبدالله على ابرز
المحطات والذكريات بالنسبه لعبد الله بن
جاد في نظرته الى تعاطي العربيه ومقاربتها
في طريقتها وتعاملها لمواجهه ظاهره غيرها
نعم هذا الحقيقه التاريخ مشرف لكن دعني
مدخل بسيط الاعلام العربي مثل ما ذكر
الاستاذ جاسر قبل قليل هو اعلام بدا
تعبويا وادرجا على مدى عقود من الزمن في
بدايه التسعينات مع خروج الام بي سي كانت
نشرات اخبار متفرقه ضمن الترفيه تحاول ان
تعرض بشكل محايد ثم في منتصف التسعينات
عندما كانت القناه الاخباريه الاولى
المؤدلجه بشكل كامل التي تبحث عن الراي
وتبحث عن التعبئه وتبحث عن الحشد وتبحث عن
هذا الخط وهذا المسار اثار الكثير من
المشكلات لدى المشاهد العربي وفي الوعي
العربي لما خرجت العربيه في 2003 كان
الرهان هو على المعلومه على الخبر بدون
تدخل للراي بدون تدخل سافر للاديولوجيا
بدون
حشد للمشاهدين بعد ذلك 2003 كانت
الحرب العراق ثم
الانتقال القاعده الى داخل السعوديه
والحرب الشرسه لخيضه ضد المملكه العربيه
السعوديه فكانت العربيه مواكبه لهذه
الاحداث بنفس القيمه الخبر والمعلومه
والتحليل الصائب الذي يعرض للمشاهد
ليتابعه ويصنعه هو بنفسه رايه فغطت
العربيه هذه الاحداث عن الارهاب بشكل
موضوعي وبشكل دقيق وخرج ايضا برنامج لاجل
علاقتي الشخصيه برنامج صناعه الموت كاول
برنامج على مستوى العالم مخصص بالكامل
لتناول موضوع الارهاب مفاهيم وجذور وحركات
وتنظيمات ورموز وعرض كل هذا
للمشاهد باسلوب
اخباري تلفزيوني يستطيع ان يفكك مثل هذه
الظاهره
يحللها ويقدم راي مستمر فيها ولله الحمد
بحكم قوه القناه وحكم وقوه التوجه في في
التناول سجل البرنامج ارقام كبيره في
المشاهده على فترات معينه
واستمر في هذا النجاح حتى ادى دوره ولم
يقف دور العربيه العربيه مستمره في تغطيه
كافه الامور بما فيها مساله الارهاب وما
يتعلق بالارهاب
يمكن
ربيع العربي من اهم كان القضايا المثيره
للجدل في مساله التعاطي الاعلام لما
رافقوا من اعمال عنف تحول فيه الصراع
السياسي الى صراع دموي صراع عنيف
هذا اد في تلك الفتره وما زال الى الى ما
سماه البعض بظاهره الانكشاف الاخباري ربما
اذا جاز لنا هذه التسميه
العربيه كيف تعاملت مع هذه القضايا قضيه
الربيع العربي وكما قلت بانها كانت من
اكثر القضايا المثيره للجدل للقسم فيها
الناس الى قسمين اولا انا اتحفظ كثيرا على
تسميه الربيع العربي هي تسميه مستورده
احنا لو كان ربيع ربي كان فرحنا في جميعا
وكان يعني خراب عربي في وقت
نعم كان في شحن لنقل شحن كثير في الجانب
كان في عمليات تهيج كانوا بحاجه انك انت
ايضا الى صوت يكون يدعم الاستقرار هنا ترى
مهمه الاعلام ليس ناقل اخبار فقط ليس فقط
ياخذ الكاميرا الى المكان ويصور الحدث ثم
ينقلها لا لا ايضا يجسد مواقف تمنى ولذلك
نحن نقول لا موضوعي وليس حيادي الموضوعيه
انك تعطي الموضوع حقه بشك كامل وتبعد عن
نقاط الزجاج طيب فيما كان هناك السياق
عمليه الاستاذ والتجييشي والتحريضي
كان الخطاب الذي تقوم فيه القناه العربيه
وقتها ورساله توصلها انه هو دعم الاستقرار
ومواجهه هذا التحديات اليستا تدخلا وليس
فرض توجهات وانما نقلا للصوره وتوضيح
للمخاطر التي تحدث والتقلبات وبالتالي لم
تكن مرغوبه من التيارات المتطرفه اللي
كانت تشجع يعني لو اخذنا في مصر يعني لان
المساله طالت في مصر اكثر من كذا من لم
نجد في هذا الموقف اللي كان فيه الوقت
اللي كان يشحن فيه الشارع المصري بشكل
للقيام والتمرد والفوضى وما حدث في الشارع
المصري لم نجد من العربيه الخطاب الذي
يعيد لا الخطاب الذي كان يتكلم عن ينقل
الصور اولا ما يحدث ويدعم حق المصريين
ويحفظ يعني الاستقرار فيها ويشجع وينقل
المعلومه كانت هناك لنجد انه في الخطاب في
تلك الفتره الخطاب لم يكن معلوماتيا كان
خطابيا وتحريضيا لم يكن هناك معلومه لم
يكن هناك نقل الصوره لم يكن هناك تضيع
مخاطر لم يكن هناك العين الكاشفه فال
ليست انكشاف يمكن بعد يمكن نستخدم احيانا
مصطلحات اشد يعني هو حاله خلنا نقول
انكشاف كامل بلغه مؤدبه يعني في الجنه
لانها ما كانت المساله قائمه الاعلام
ولذلك هذه الخطوره الاعلام المؤدلج لا
يعيش طويلا لانه يخدم غرض معين فتره معينه
ثم يموت ولذلك لو نجد انا ليس لدي ارقام
لكن نجد مسار العربيه تاخذ المسار المتطور
في علاقه المشاهد فيها من ناحيه موثوقيه
وهذا جانب مهم حتى عندما اظهرت قناه الحدث
ايضا اصبح هناك حتى العربيه متنفس تواصلي
اعمق واقرب الى الناس واكثر لنقل انسانيه
فان سنه الاعلام وليس فقط يعني الماده
الخبريه الجافه ويعني من اللا
فت انك توصل للانساني مع الناس ويعني من
من ما نراه الى يعني الواقع الى منازلهم
اسال هنا من دبي استاذ عبد الله العتيبي
يعني استاذ عبد الله بعد هذا الحكي
والانكشاف ربما الاعلامي او انكشاف
السياسي كما ذكر خالد اين تتجه العربيه في
تغطياتها يعني كيف يمكن النظر الى مستقبل
العربيه في تغطياتها وفي تواجدها في
الميدان اولا باول
ما في شك عشرون عام كافيه للحكم على قناه
العربيه انها قادره دائما على التطور
وتقديم ما يجذب المشاهد وما يقنع
المشاهد بمصداقيته فكره العربيه كفكره هي
فكره
تمثل جزء من قوه السياسه الناعم هو من
القوه الناعمه للسياسه وهي تجلت على مدى
هذه العشرين عاما وتجلت ايضا في الموقف
مما كان يعرف بالربيع العربي وهو الربيع
الاصوليه التخريب وتجلت في العديد من
المواقف يعني كان هناك تحديات حقيقيه كانت
تحتاج الى
عقلانيه و واقعيه في تغطيه الاحداث الكبرى
راهنت العربيه على الموقف السياسي
العقلاني والملتزم بعيدا عن اي قوائيه نحن
نتذكر مثلا احداث القاعده نتذكر
حرب 2006 وحزب الله اللبناني ونتذكر ايضا
لما جاءت
ما في شك نشره الرابعه منذ بدات وتخصصها
في الشان السعودي بحكم ان المشاهد السعودي
القناه السعوديه والمشاهد السعودي
مشاهد مهم جدا لدي من الوعي والادراك
والتاثير الشيء الكبير وبالتالي كان
نشرت الرابعه قادره على ملامسه اسئله
المشاهد السعودي وعلى تقديم الاجوبه
المهمه له وعلى المشاركه في ترتيب
اولوياته وتغطيه ما يهتم به وهذا نجاح
صراحه مهم لنشره الرابعه ولاصدقائنا في
نشره الرابعه ايش رايك استاذ ياسر في نشره
الرابعه خاصه نشره الرابعه كملت هي اول
كانت هي اول نشره تقدم من هذا الاستديو
استديو استديوهاتنا في الرياض
شكرا لكما
اعتقد ان قناه العربيه ملات فراغا كبيرا
يعني من المهم
للمشاهد وخاصه في العالم العربي ان تكون
هناك منصات اخباريه
مميزه
تحمل رؤى ووجهات نظر مختلفه ويبقى الحكم
للمتلقي تكلم في العالم العربي لو لم تكن
العربيه موجوده لكان هناك اعتقد فراغ كبير
لكان هناك فراغ كبير صعبا يملا
دبي الى الفقره الاقتصاديه مع نادين هاني
كل عام وانت بخير
شكرا خالد وفاطمه وكل عام وانتم وكل يعني
للعاملين بالعربيه بالف خير بالطبع متابعه
سوق الاسهم السعوديه تمثل المحتوى الاكبر
لنا ضمن نشرات الاقتصاد بدايه بفقرات
تحديث الاسواق على قناه العربيه منذ
الصباح التي تعطي المستثمر معلومات موجزه
حول ابرز ما يحرك الاسواق خلال اليوم سواء
عالميا او محليا وايضا اهم ما تتراقبه
الاسواق من بيانات واجتماعات مهمه وهو ما
حارسنا عليهم منذ انطلاق الاسواق العربيه
تقديم كل ما يهم المستثمر بشكل خاص نبض
السوق الاسواق العربيه غداء عمل وجرس
الاغلاق برامج اصبحت مرجعا للاعلام
الاقتصادي منذ ان انطلقت عام 2005 بفريقها
المتخصص بخبره صحفيه واعلاميه واقتصاديه
وماليه فريق واكبا دون ملل اهم وابرز
الاخبار والاحداث والمتغيرات التي حركت
جوانب الاقتصاد وقادت مخت قطاعات المال
والاعمال محليا في منطقه الخليج وفي
مقدمتها السوق السعوديه وعربيا وعالميا
على مدار السنوات الماضيه وحتى الان وهو
ما سنواصل الالتزام به اليوم وغدا سوق
الاسهم السعوديه كان لها نصيب الاسد من
تغطيتنا منذ البدايه
2006 عام القمه والقاع العام الذي تغيرت
بعده اليه عمل سوق الاسهم والسوق الماليه
السعوديه ليفتح المجال امام تطوير
التشريعات والقوانين واللوائح المنظمه
للسوق من حيث التداول وتجديد المراقبه
وفرض الغرامات على المخالفين 2006 لا ينسى
ما هذا لتغيير منظومه العمل في السوق
لتعزز مكانه التداول كاهم واكبر سوق عربي
بقيمه سوقيه تتجاوز التريليون و700 مليار
دولار حاليا فما الذي حدث في 2006 هو عام
لن ننساه كان العامل اكثر تقلبا وتاثيرا
بدءا من القمه التي بلغها تعصي في 25
فبراير فوق مستوى العشرين الف وست مئه
نقطه واستقيم التداولات يوميه كانت تجاوزت
ال 50 مليار ريال ثم جاءت التقلبات
الشديده والهبوط المتواصل باكثر من الف
نقطه يوميا كانت ايام صعبه هو ما بدا في
صباح 26 فبراير ومتابعه من تغييرات
وقرارات لاحقه غير التوجهات سوق الماليه
بشكل عام حتى يومنا هذا نذكر هنا بان مؤشر
تاسي وصل الى ادنى مستوى له في مارس 2009
حيث سجل نحو 4000 نقطه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
غير انه شكلي كان مختلف تماما عم نحكي عن
17 سنه لورا ولكن كانت اياما صعبه بالفعل
خاصه لانه بحينها كان جميع السعوديين
لديهم اسهم وبالتالي كانت ظاهره شراء
افراد وبالتالي عند الوصول الى القمه ومن
ثم النزول الصعب الذي حدث بالسوق فقد
الكثير جنى عمرهم وبالتالي كانت ايام صعبه
ومليئه بالالم لانه عم نتحدث عن خساره عدد
كبير من الناس لجنى العمر بالتالي من هنا
بدات الحاجه
للتشريعات التي لحقت بعد ذلك بالطبع كان
لنشرات قسم الاقتصاد في العربيه الحضور
والتواجد الاكثر بين اوساط المستثمرين
والمهتمين باسواق المال من السعوديين
لمتابعه حزم التغييرات التي عاقبت هبوط
سوق الاسهم والتي كانت بوتيره شبه يوميه
كان لنا لقاءات حصريه مع المسؤولين
السعوديين في تصريحات كان يتراقبها
الكثيرون لحظه بلحظه
[موسيقى]
ومنذ تاسيس الهيئه عمل جماس سحيمي الرئيس
السابق لهيئه السوق الماليه على الارتقاء
بنوعيه التداولات في السوق السعوديه وهو
الدور الذي تعاهد الرئيس الجديد الدكتور
عبد الرحمن التويجري بالعمل على تطويره في
المرحله المقبله نتراجع الكبير في اسعار
الاسهم
لتاثيره المباشر على ملايين المواطنين ولا
يتلاءم مع الوضع الاقتصادي العامه الذي
تعيشه بلادنا من ازدهار اقتصادي والتي
تتمتع فيه بمعدلاته نمو عاليه
في ميزانيه الحكومه وميزان المدفوعات ولا
يوجد تضخم
[موسيقى]
على كلن يعني هذا التغيير اللي حدث بحينها
كان الناس يحتاجون الى رؤيه تغيير يحتاجون
الى رؤيه اخذ المسؤولين بجديه الخساره
الضخمه التي حصلت في السوق السعوديه منذ
ذلك الحين بظن تاخذ القرار انه يتحول
السوق الى مؤسساتي ادخال المؤسسات المحليه
والعالميه لحتى يصير استثمار الافراد يشكل
نسبه اقل من السوق ولا يعود سوق متقلب على
هوى استثمارات الافراد وليس المؤسسات فاذا
التحول الاكبر نحو العالميه بدا فعليا من
بعد سلسله خطوات ولكن بيونيو 2015 مع
السماح للمستثمرين الاجانب المؤهلين
بالدخول في السوق الماليه السعوديه بعد ان
تم تحديث قواعد وشروط استثمار الاجانب
مرتين خلال عامي 2016 و2018 كما كانت ابرز
ثمار منظومه حزم الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه
والماليه بعد اعوام قليله من اطلاق رؤيه
المملكه 2030 هي ترقيه سوق الاسهم
السعوديه الى مصاف الاسواق الناشئه في عام
2019 من قبل اكبر ثلاث شركات عالميه
للمؤشرات ام السي اي فوت راسل واسم بيدا
جونز
[موسيقى]
سوق الاسهم السعوديه عن كثب وذلك لانه بدا
من اليوم يستطيع المستثمر الاجنبي شراء
المباشر في سوق عبر
ترخيص يحصل عليه كاكيو اف اي كوالي فايف
[موسيقى]
نادين بالفعل يعني التقارير ايجابيه جدا
حول انعكاس فتحه السوق السعوديه على اسواق
المنطقه بشكل عام وتحديدا اسواق الامارات
[موسيقى]
صعب واحد يشوف حاله من سنوات فريق الاسواق
العربيه تواجد بشكل بارز اثناء التحضيرات
الاوليه وحتى الادراج الاكبر في السوق
السعوديه حيث شاهد ديسمبر من عام 2019
المحطه الاهم الاكبر ظهورا في عناوين
الاخبار الاقتصاديه محليا وعالميا هي طرح
ارامكو الذي جمع سته وتسعين مليار ريال او
25 مليار و600 مليون دولار ليكون في حينها
اكبر اكتتاب عام في تاريخ اسواق الاسهم
العالميه ومع اكتتاب ارامكو اصبحت سوق
الاسهم السعوديه في ذلك الحين تاسع اكبر
بورصه في العالم بقيمه سوقيه لشركات
المدرجه تصل الى تريليونين و300 مليار
دولار بعد طول انتظار تستقبل سوق الاسهم
السعوديه اليوم سهم ارامكو بعد انتهاء
الاكتتاب العام الاولي الاكبر في العالم
بقيمه 25 مليارا و600 مليون دولار بطلبات
شراء فاقه الاسهم المعروضه
بما يقارب خمسه اضعاف
ادراج اسهم ارامكو تحت مظله
[موسيقى]
الوجه
وعلى الرغم من الظروف المفاجئه والصعبه
التي فرضتها ازمه تفشي كورونا بالاعوام
الثلاثه الماضيه الا ان سوق السعوديه وصلت
التطوير والتحديات ليتم الاعلان عن ادراج
وتداول اسهم شركه مجموعه تداول السعوديه
القابضه تم ادراجها بالسوق الرئيسيه
اعتبارا من الثامن من ديسمبر 2021 وذلك
بعد تحولها الى شركه قابضه باسم مجموعه
تداول السعوديه قبيله طرح العام الاولي
ياتي الطرح كتويج لنشاط الطروحات العامه
الاوليه ليزداد عمق السوق مع تنوع
المنتجات والادوات الاستثماريه المدرجه
فيها بعدد يتجاوز 220 شركه حاليا ماذا
تغير في الهيكل الجديد شركه السوق الماليه
تداول تحولت الى شركه قابضه باسم مجموعه
تداول السعوديه وتحت مظلتها اربع شركات هي
تداول كسوق للاوراق الماليه وشركه مركز
مقاصه الاوراق الماليه مقص وشركه مركز ايد
الاوراق الماليه ايداع وشركه موفندا
الجديده والمتخصصه في الخدمات والحلول
التقنيه القائمه على الابتكار وبدا اليوم
ادراج وتداول سهم شركه مجموعه تداول
السعوديه القابضه في السوق الرئيسيه بعد
ان تم الاكتتاب بالاسهم بسعر 105
قد طرحت 36 مليون سهم تمثل 30% من
راسمالها للاكتتاب العام تم تخصيص 70%
منها للشركات و30% للافراد
التغطيه او الاسواق العربيه بشكل لتعرفونه
الان لم يبدا مع انطلاقه العربيه
بالتالي لا نستطيع اختصار مسيره 18 عاما
من التغطيه لاسواق المنطقه وخاصه سوق
الاسهم السعوديه واخبار المنطقه ببضع
الدقائق هذه كانت بعض المحطات لكن ربما
الانجاز الاكبر هو انه اعتاد الناس على
متابعه الاخبار الاقتصاديه معنا اصبحت
ضروره ان يتابعوننا ويعلمون بكل ما يدور
من اخبار اقتصاديه في المنطقه لانها
بالفعل تمس بحياتهم اليوميه كون ايضا دول
الخليج هي مقر الاستثمارات ضخمه فاذا
العبره لا نستطيع ان نختصرها بالماضي
وبهذه الفقره بل بالحاضر والمستقبل نعطكم
بان نبقى السباقين فيه بتغطيه سوق الاسهم
السعوديه وغيرها من الاسواق والاخبار
الاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
عملت العربيه طوال سنوات على 20 على تعزيز
فكره الاعتدال ونبذ الافكار المتطرفه عبر
الكثير من البرامج من ابرزها برنامج صناعه
الموت فضلا عن الكثير من الافلام
الوثائقيه احدث اصدارات العربيه في هذا
كان بودكاست جمعت الذي تقدمه الزميل هدى
الصالح
تفضلي فاطمه في الاستوديو طبعا الكاتبه
الصحفيه الزميله هدى الصالح اهلا بك معنا
هدى يعني
سنوات كثيره لها خبره في هذا المجال
الاسلاميه 19 سنه تحديدا وانت تتعاملي
معاهم تبحثي عنهم تكتبي عنهم وتقراي عنهم
هدى يعني قولي لنا ربما ابرز المحطات التي
مررت بها مع العربيه في تغطياتك لهذه
الجماعات الاسلاميه طبعا كانت ابرز محطه
هي بدايه ما عرف بالربيع العربي لكن انا
اعتقد المسمى الحقيقي او الادق موسم
الحصاد للجماعات الراديكاليه المسلحه كما
اطلق عليه ايمن الظواهري واسامه بن لادن
واعتبروه كذلك وهو بالفعل كان يعني زمن
نهضه وصحوه جديده للجماعات المسلحه خلال
العشر سنوات
فبدايه العمل مع العربيه كان من هذا
التاريخ
وحاولت اني اغطي مع كافه التي المحسوبه في
يعني في داخل التيار الصحوي سواء السروريه
سواء الاصوليه الجهاديه السلفيه الجهاديه
او التيارات الاخرى في مثلا في افغانستان
في باكستان وغيرها فنحاول انه نقرا شو
المفارقات اللي كانت في ديك الفتره وايضا
من اشق السياسي لهذه الجماعات وهي المضخه
النظريه لهذه الجماعات المسلحه
يعني ماذا قدمت العربيه لك من تسهيلات
ربما ومن
خلينا نقول لاجل انك تقدري تغطيها بشكل
ادق وافضل اشكرك على هذا السؤال
تفضلي طبعا انا اشكرك صراحه على هذا
السؤال لان هذه شهاده يعني واجب ذكرها ان
الاستاذ
الاستاذ ممدوح المهيني كان هو اللي في
البدايه اللي طلب مني فقط ان يعني اعتكف
على هذه المواضيع يعني انه قليل جدا ما
تلاقي في في مجالنا بالذات في المجتمعاتنا
العربيه او في الاعلام العربي ان هناك من
يركز على او يفهم ويعني يقيم مهمه الصحافه
المتخصصه فكان للسيد ممدوح معتني جدا في
هذا الاطار فكل صحفي كان يعني يضع في
موقعه
وما يجيده في هذا المجال فطلب يعني
وشجاني على ان اعتكف على هذه المواد ولا
اخرج عنها فكانت عندي مساحه وقت لقراءه
ومتابعه سواء الكتب
والاصداراتهم ومطبوعاتهم حساباتهم في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في تيليجرام في
تويتر
تحتاجي للتفرغ التام حتى تراقبي كل شيء في
هذا يعني ما هو سهل تكوني متخصصه فقط بانك
تتابعي الاخبار او تتابع احداث لا تخصص
لابد ان تقرا يعني تحاول قدر الامكان ان
تقرا معظم ما يخرجون من اصدارات حتى
تقيمها وتقارنها ما بين الامس واليوم واش
التطور لحدث لها
كاتب الصحفي شكرا لك شكرا شكرا
لم يجبان الخليجيه من عن شاشه العربيه
التي تابعت اهم وابرز احداث الخليج طوال
عقدين من الزمن من السياسه الى القضايا
الاجتماعيه وليس انتهاء بالثقافه والرياضه
نتابع
[تصفيق]
تجد اليوم في الامارات مرحله التصويت
النهائيه لانتخابات المجلس الوطني
الاتحاديه الاعلان عن الاسامي ستكون في
العاصمه ابوظبي في المركز الرئيسي
سجلت السلطات العمانيه سبع وفيات جديده
بسبب اعصار الشاهين
[موسيقى]
العالقين الاسراع في اصلاح البنيه التحتيه
والوقائع اعصار شاهين الذي ضرب عمان
[تصفيق]
كيف ترى سلطنه عمان مشهد الدول او الازمات
في المنطقه هناك ازمات صعبه معقده وشائكه
[تصفيق]
هذا المسجد يمتد عمره لاكثر من
1400 عام
سنكون معكم من العلا على الهواء مباشره
الذي سيتم توقيعه في هذه القمه المباركه
البدايه من الكويت الواقعه في اقصى جمال
الخليفه العربي
معنا من الجبال فضل البوعينين مجلس الشورى
استاد تفضل حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه
ومبروك علينا وعليك
العربيه
وخليني ابدا معك انت متابع للعربيه
بالتاكيد وضحت ضيوفها البارزين ومتخصصين
ودائما تصحبنا في الكثير من القضايا التي
تهم المواطن الخليجي ما نصيبه برايك يعني
او نصيب الشان الخليجي الى اي مدى وصل في
قناه العربيه براي فضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم في خالد انا لم
اسمع السؤال ولكن ابدا اولا
بتهنئه العربيه بعمل عشرين عشرين عاما من
التميز
والموضوعيه والنزاهه والانتشار وايضا على
هذه الجهود الاعلاميه خاصه في الاعلام
الاقتصادي الذي اثرت تاثيرا كبيرا في
المجتمع العربي واصبح له صدا كبيرا خاصه
وان العربيه تنحى منحه لتعزيز التنميه
والاستقرار وتقديم الخبر بما يساعد على
نشر هذه الثقافه ثقافه البناء والتنميه
والاستقرار وهذا امر كنا في امس الحاجه له
في الفضاء الاعلامي شكرا للعربيه ولجميع
العاملين فيه على كل ما قدموا من ج
هود الماضيه ان شاء الله تسمعني الان الان
اسمعك كنت اسال عن نصيب المشاهد الخليجي
من قناه العربيه من برامجها من الاخبار
التي تقدمها التحليلات وغيرها
ان نصيب الاسد خاصه وان العربيه اصبحت تبث
نشرات اخبا
ريه صفه
الدول
وبالتالي اصبح هناك توجيه مباشر لتغطيه
شامله لاخبار هذه الدول وبالتالي نرى
اليوم انتشار كبير
العربي نرى ايضا ارتفاع كبير في عدد
المشاهدات ليس من خلال القناه وبسها ولكن
حتى من
المنصات الاخرى الاعلاميه الاخرى منصات
الاجتماع التواصل الاجتماعي وهذا له تا
ثير في جانبين اساسيين حقيقي
ين سيد فضل يعني تغطيتها وتواجدها على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ومواكبه التطورات
في التغطيات ونقل الخبر الى المشاهد كيف
ترى تجربه العربيه في اثراء المشاهد
الخليجي وفي نقل مواضيعه وقضاياه
الدول الخليجيه على وجه الخصوص الدول
العربيه
وعندما تربط بين منصات موجهه عن طريق
القناه مباشره والمنصات المتخصصه على
الوسائط الاجتماعيه اضافه الى موقعها
الاخباري ايضا على الانترنت فبالتالي هي
تصل الى كل منزل وكل مشاهد عربي وما يهمني
في هذا الجانب حقيقه انها تلامس الايجابي
في المشاهد العربي وتنميه وايضا حمله على
التفاعل الايجابي مع كل ما يهم بتنميه
المجتمع العربي ان كان اقتصاديا سياسيا او
ثقافيا او امنيا نعم
مساله سريعه اذا حاولنا ابرز حذف تابعته
على قناه العربيه
اولا بما ذكرته المقدمه الاخ مدين وهي
انهيار السوق الاسمر اعتقد ان ذلك كان من
اكثر المشاهد الى من انا اتكلم بجانب
الاقتصادي فقط واما الجانب المفرح حقيقه
نقل العربيه
لبث مباشر
لتصريحات سمولي العهد الامير محمد بن
سلمان واطلاق رؤيه المملكه 2030 الرؤيه
المباركه التي اثرت في التي التي احدثت
تحول الاقتصاديا كبيرا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ثم ادراج ارامكو ثم المشروعات
الك
برى عن طريق سمو ولي العهد الام
ير محمد ال
نيون القنديه البحر الاحمر الدرعيه بوابه
الدرعيه مؤخرا المربع الجديد كل هذه
الاحداث الاقتصاديه كانت مهمه بالنسبه لي
فقط ولكن للمجتمع السعودي ولجميع الدول
الباحثه التنميه والتحول الاقتصادي هذا من
اهم الاحداث التي حقيقه شاهدتها في العربي
ولكن جميع
الاحداث العربيه مهمه لكل مشاهد عربي اختم
اذا كان لي اقل من دقيقه اذا سمحت نعم
يبدو اننا
وقتنا معك للاسف سيد فاضل البوعنان
السعودي
نعتذر منك نختم هذه الساعه مشاهدينا لكن
تغطيتنا مستمره لعيد العربيه العشرين احمد
الهادي معكم على
راس الساعه شكرا لكم والى اللقاء